whoa greetings and salutations beloved
friends family and faculty what up today
I want to discuss the topic of life long
ascent because I think it's a topic that
is as relevant to our near grads as it
is to our grandmothers I'm concerned
that we're letting a false set of rules
guide our life's trajectory as it stands
now we learn first then we mature then
we retire basically we grow we blossom
and then we atrophy pretty anti-climatic
pretty anticlimactic wouldn't you agree
so allow me to step in with a counter
example we have on this very campus in
the basement of our library a posse of
golden citizens who show up on time on
snow days and on weekends to show us how
it's done while bonded together by the
eponymous works of philanthropist
Bernardo sure these mature students are
indeed lifelong learners and lovers of
life they're 80 year old ring leader is
a man named Ed Landerman whose joy is
ubiquitous and I do hope you're out
there he acts like a small-town mayor
who loves his gig while many of his
senior contemporaries may see their
roads narrowing it is still pathfinding
and forging ahead he's still looking and
he's still hungry lifelong ascent is a
matter of keeping things interesting for
yourself changing it up keeping it fresh
and only kicking it old school as a
break from tangling with the new
unfortunately though this is not the
zeitgeist of our times the educational
pendulum has shifted from the liberal
arts toward a focus on professionalism
ie jobs history too seems to favor a
condescension of people into singular
specialties I am a blank we say I have
but one thing to offer humankind
my friends that sentiment is loco our
capacity is infinite if only we choose
to recognize it enter the polymath
someone magnificently expansive who
could play the full court I'm not
talking about being good at jeopardy or
trivial pursuit I'm speaking about
individuals who work vigorously across
multiple disciplines Leonardo da Vinci
is a classic polymath even after three
years in our graduate school with the
full Pantheon that my disposal leo is
still my favorite artist he's a hardcore
capital a artist no doubt but da Vinci's
in our hearts and minds because he's a
conceptual artist a painter a sculptor
an architect a musician a scientist a
mathematician an engineer and inventor a
geologist a botanist and a writer he
worked in the realm of ideas not
disciplines pretty cool guy mothers of
presidents rarely get their props so
I'll shout out miss lillian carter
mother of President Jimmy Carter as
another case study in too legit to quit
miss Lillian was a nurse practitioner an
author and a social activist adamantly
in support of desegregation but wait
there's more at the ripe age of 68 she
applied for the Peace Corps and headed
to Mumbai later that life she started a
made-for-tv movie opposite Lucille Ball
Nick Copernicus the name I'm sure we all
know was a heavy hitter too best known
is the astronomer who formulated the
heliocentric cosmology there by
displacing the Earth from the center of
the universe he was also a mathematician
a physician a Quadra lingual polyglot a
classical scholar a translator an artist
a Catholic cleric a governor a military
leader a diplomat and anaconda
missed but Polly mafia is nothing new
it's existed for eons and it spans
across time gender and culture name by
the Guinness Book of World Records is
the most versatile female competitor
babe dietrichson dropped it down in golf
basketball and track and field she's not
just a world champion she's a universal
champion Sequoia is another
cross-disciplinary badass known to many
as a Cherokee silversmith he created the
written form of the Cherokee language in
his free time he completed the language
in 1821 BAM had it adopted by night or
by 1825 literacy insurers perpetuity
Sequoia could see this many years out
and new action needed to be taken the
interesting thing about polymaths is
that they seek and generate endless
connections across human achievement for
them and here at carnegie mellon
disciplines know no boundaries instead
of being annoyed by continuous change we
welcome it polymath brains can sense the
tectonic shift that precedes a paradigm
shift to be honest my brain is over
excited just thinking about lateral
thinking I want to tell I want you all
to share in with me so I'm going to try
to entice you with a few other polymaths
Ben Franklin the print maker polymath
hildegard been been in polymath Thomas
Jefferson is one michael jackson is one
be a beatboxer and a businessman if
you're willing to access and celebrate
your whole brain Hungarian psychology
professor Mikhail Csikszentmihalyi
formerly the head of the University of
Chicago psychology department believes
people are most happy when they are in a
state of flow that is a state of
concentration or complete absorption
with the task at hand his noted work on
the study of happiness and creativity
defines the state of flow as a deeply
inspired mental state no matter the
topic of contemplation
flow is an optimal state of intrinsic
motivation where we're fully immersed in
what we are doing it's a feeling
everyone here has had a feeling of great
absorption engagement fulfillment and
skill when temporal concerns such as
time food ego and the self drop away as
I begin to wrap here I want to say that
the path of Marie Curie is perfectly
fine by me what you want is two elements
on the periodic table then focus and
find them make the discovery but know
that most of us aren't going to be so
monocular we need to trust ourselves to
make unique contributions the key to
long-term advantage is not based on
position where you are but on progress
what you are becoming so follow your
intuition and do all the things you love
simultaneously let's maximize the
challenge and maximize the journey let's
enable ourselves to do it all read a
biography eat out stand on the shoulders
of giants drop it like it's hot there's
one last polymath that I've discovered
very recently and I've written her in
for today her name is Hedy Lamarr most
who know her know her as a successful
film actress from the 30s and 40s with
the star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
much of her early notoriety came from a
1933 film called ecstasy where she
played the first nude scene in cinematic
history following the outbreak of World
War two Hedy Lamarr wanted to do more
for the Allied effort than just
contribute propaganda so she teamed up
with the American avant-garde composer
Georgeann tile and they developed a
torpedo guidance system whereby a signal
was distributed over several frequencies
over several frequencies to protect it
from enemy jamming in 1942 they were
awarded a joint patent for their secret
communication system Lamar's
contribution was key for the military in
the cuban missile crisis in 62 and
remains key for more
recent wireless technologies like our
cell phones for the record hitting it
out of the park is not the converse of a
belly flop both actions can be executed
masterfully as to merit the use of the
term success life longest scent is about
leading our lives Carnegie Mellon has
been a wonderful petri dish warm in all
the right places as a last personal
aside I want to extend a special thank
you to Carnegie Mellon for the free
tampons I've been thank you ladies I've
been so impressed by the gender equality
that this gesture represents that I will
most definitely implement the practice
in my own startup business pathfinders
will find so I'll hope to cross paths
with you one day in this stratosphere or
another whoop there it is happy
graduation
you